ah ah ah ah já se tratar de lei do oge
galera parando aqui o vídeo só pedimos e
clicar em gostei logo norte não chega
porque implica uma perda de um amigo
aqui caí porque não gostei em baixo a pm
vai esquecer de falar num videoclip
gostei mas valeu
olha só que apareceu aqui é meu amigo é
como diz é a famosa frase que é vivo
sempre se estressa vou deixar
condicionado ligado porque está quente
que são canais são paulo está quente
otta frei então combinado vou deixar
ligado porque lá fora ou quente ou frio
aqui dentro permanece a mesma
temperatura tanta coisa aconteceu em
pois é para todas assumir está fazendo
aqui porque tá dando tempo eu estou
viajando muito muito muito brother meu
deus do céu eu viajei tanto que está
começando com um amigo meu esse dia para
falar ele disse assim pra mim aí aonde
eu descarto na nigéria ele disse lixo eu
nunca sei quanto tá brincando o que tu
viajo tanto que pode ser que tudo esteja
mesmo na nigéria e eu tava e perto com a
mesma cabeça da pessoa e das pessoas ao
redor também porque eu tô num carro na
casa do caetano está grande galera de
palheta para do norte amanhã eu tenho um
show e nove da noite aí eu cheguei na
cidade as pessoas ficam chitali a eu
estou entendendo nada a galera de rapaz
e acabar comemorou atravessou o oceano
para fazer um show inclusive 19 agora de
novembro eu estou em paulo afonso na
bahia e no dia 10 em salvador bahia
vamos lá graças do site o inter são
imunes à volta do que não foi o o meia
seu que vocês
o fuso horário do lugar deixa a gente
doido também que foi gravado no japão
japão inclusive tem esse episódio aí no
canal a um dos episódios da série que
está saindo toda quinta feira às 20
horas pitcho a família agente jorge
contou um negócio diferente do japão tem
uma lombra nessuno meu bom ou ruim de
som todo mundo me no brasil era votado
em mim também me acabei fã do meu noite
e se japão todinho que deu do
domingo dia 11 uma coisa acesa e meu
cérebro estava assim tenho que roda no
japão todo nerd no japão que estou me
acostumando confusão na canoa rápidos em
estados unidos quando chega nos estados
unidos não sei que ora é no japão tarde
noite no brasil tá meio dia e e deu
certo assim entrava no palco e miami boa
noite belém do pará inclusive show em
belém do pará no dia 17 de novembro na
arena mangueirinhas 16 manaus amazonas
de 15 boa pista orai ban e gravamos
estados unidos nova york a lala episódio
3 no canal assistir você tinha tamanho
da boneca assistir o episódio tem e não
sabe o tamanho da boneca como a
moçambique na áfrica cara muito macho
que país maravilhoso nos ambiente carlos
levy um beijo pra todo mundo e
moçambique eu fui daquelas feirinha
olhando as coisinhas que ela quer me
vender um bem de guepardo robertinha
deixam mais entende de pardos enquanto é
isso aí eles em dólar que me quieres
desta manhã um dia de espera é de leite
punho safari morrendo de medo de me
preparei anos também estava de serviço
no ramo safari obteve no youtube e léo
atacando gente matando eu gosto de vê lo
em realidade vai lutar com que eu não
larguei um medo que o couro cabelo
cachecol pego depois capita adiantado
mesmo local era assim e uma vez eu
estava a correr parto eu tive quando
mike tyson gay pardo tem outro tiro e
foi mike tyson depardon eu vou lhe for e
foi com rigor e com rigor e e subir
marcou lei para bater o guarda estava
subindo domingo
eu disse que não ia conseguir quando vê
pardo avançou e menos sorte ele
escorregou e caiu limpa eu [ __ ] que
pariu se fosse eu tinha me pagar tô e
ele disse você acha que eu reparei
escorregou em que permite mas
subitamente ele diz assim nesta sábado
animais são as mães são vários que
existem muitos mais servat o cupim de
sucupira de junho cup eu estava com
minha cabeça como a água ainda novela
floresta meu cadastro desamarrou da
minha bota escadas na bota é o impedirei
a cabeça
lá em cima da árvore no auge para amar é
a minha bota
quando eu subi os cupins tinham comido
toda a cabaça estava pena água pendurada
o cara me tiram e aí meu amigo o
episódio moçambique áfrica do sul e está
aí no meu canal também você assistir o
episódio 6 tapam legalzinho e as coisas
que eu não gostei nem fim do vídeo não
tem nem do episódio eu conto no show que
inclusive eu estou no dia 24 de novembro
para o rio de janeiro gerenciar e no
taolu só quando tem grande
estadao.com.br e aí número de vinil até
o tempo todo é doido bem particular a
cama na cama de hotel a ver com a minha
banheiro porque eu não gosto de limpar o
negócio com o papel não sabe e gosta com
o jardim da água e às vezes eu cheguei
da fmb que é um jogador que tocava aqui
e obter aqui sabem que têm que dar
aquela caminhada ele possui fabinho não
pode fechar se na massa e fiquei mal
beber só que essa caminhada da equipa
que é amigo moda tanto sabe o que me
incomoda no bbb eu gosto mais um
chuveirinho e cujo mérito vai com um
chuveiro entendeu que ficou muito
patente até meu carro acha que tem que
fazer um paradigma da porta é aquela
porta aquele olho mágico toda hora eu
sou curioso fica olhando a recitar
passando alguém corredores têm um futuro
negócio que a pessoa tem que estar 100%
na feitoria mágico porque se ela sai prá
cá só oi de cabeça à frente a toda hora
me assustando quem é ea cabeça da pessoa
ativa ao saber do nada entrou a bola do
tamanho da casa do carro é é um prato
assim o dia de seu carmona e aloísio
chegou com a maquiagem eo vermelho
quando entrou na rede você quer uit a
coisa inclusive já esteve a assistir
hoje para fazer um vídeo que você então
fique ligado no dia que eu postar alguma
coisa no instagram
se você me segue não levantava pontocom
ou no twitter no facebook tal aporte
mensal para 20 deixando like voado aqui
beleza foi para a índia também dessa vez
não foi trabalhando essa lista de férias
neva coast também que o seu filho dizer
muito legal o cara que ficou pra atender
a gente do hotel parecia muito a voz de
michael jackson de mais de mais de mais
mas não está
tá ensino estamos a ser muito mais fácil
passar o diretor escuta a voz de michael
jackson em noite sim tá um pouco de medo
a começar do rio começa a escutar tudo
era num ano na noite despedindo da dacon
escorpião para ver o que vai levar à
tarde não é barato não não tem barata eu
digo não nunca não não vem na tailândia
no meu barato não vem da tailândia de
mim eu estou aqui hoje ultima de
comemorar a data de novo como barata meu
amigo buemi gol do comparado no brasil
comemorado aqui a carne mais barata na
tailândia é comemorada na índia eu
liguei pro de arraiá da paz landim agora
é limpa e gente toma banho uma vacina e
tudo o meu deus me barata tem comemorar
a atmos quando bota no óleo ele frita
tudo fique crocante tem mais nada não
fica com um gol de pipoca e onde foi
então tome pipoca tal que é meu saque já
que barata pai todo mundo aqui com
barata também o emblema é o fogo agora o
baralho nele a marca começa a força da
nato agora foi lá pegou barato acaba
disse que não tinha barbato chegou para
mim e disse que não tem mais barata não
mas tem lacraia de que só como se for
barato porque digo porque têm acreditado
é a barata não sai caro e eu esqueci meu
caráter nota e por conta de viver muito
nessas viagens eu não tenho tempo para
gravar o vídeo aqui pra vocês mas eu
decidi com uma coisa eu vou fazer mais o
próximo ano de shows o ano de 2020 eu
vou fazer um show dele inteiro quando
acabar 2020 é eu vou escolher outra
cidade foi gravado o show e vou parar de
fazer show é pelo brasil inteiro então
essa é a última chance pra você que é
assistir o show outro dia eu volto a
fazer mas eu vou me dedicar agora a
vídeos aqui pra você está aqui e esse é
o meu lugar eu gosto de fazer muita
coisa e os projetos enquanto muita
vontade de fazer mas infelizmente também
precisa de tempo para escrever para
poder pensar e vou lá para fazer o
melhor pra você e se você nunca assisti
a um show meu ao vivo mesmo que você
tenha assistido da netflix o adulto
último que saiu agora se pode precisar
instalar ou no youtube que tem uma
menina
mais de 60 milhões de views tenho o
paroxismo tem quase 70 milhões de
visualizações a galera ama o show ver
pela internet ver com a família é muito
legal mais ver ao vivo é outra energia o
local a junto é muito bacana tem grande
no meu site e 12 episódios estão aí no
canal çom oito taças 18 até agora eu
acho que saiu 5 e em falta mais três
então maratona e meia hora cada um se
pode assistir tá não esquece clicarem
gostei cara aqui embaixo porque gostei
se você gostou desse vídeo ou até para
finalizar estou aqui ainda o enguiço
calma eu quero que você comente aqui em
baixo ou a parada eu viajei muito eu tô
sabendo muito e tenho muita coisa para
contar çom vários lugares seis apóiam eu
fazer tipo dia em que eu fui do país o
dia que eu fui na irlanda o dia em que
eu fui na suíça o dia em que eu fui se
diferenciou não voltem aqui nos
comentários e pode votar só um dedinho
fazendo assim ou você pode botar a
sintero por candy se você gosta de
conhecer os lugares é isso aí tamo junto
é no flamengo e corinthians